bonjour à tous cet après midi sur public
sénat vous allez pouvoir suivre sur
notre antenne le discours de nicolas
sarkozy en direct de l'école militaire
aux alentours de 17 heures le président
de la république devrait officialiser la
réintégration de la france dans l'otan
mais tout de suite direction l'hémicycle
où se poursuit l'examen du projet de loi
pour le développement économique de
l'outre-mer alors que la crise aux
antilles continué hier un gendarme a été
blessé par un tir de carabine à la
réunion la discussion reprend à
l'article 1er sur la mise en place des
zones franches d'activités c'est une des
mesures phares de ce projet de loi la
discussion reprend donc plus exactement
à l'amendement de 137 déposé par la
sénatrice gélita hoarau elle souhaite
voir cette mesure étendue aux
micro-entreprises bonne séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi pour le
développement économique de l'outre-mer
dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus à l'amendement 237 au
sein de l'article 1er malo hoarau vous
le présentez vous avez la parole mais si
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues c'est un amendement de
précisions il s'agit de faire bénéficier
de la zone franche globale d'activité
les entreprises soumises orge régime
fiscal dit micro c'est à dire celles
dont le chiffre d'affaires hors taxes
annuel n'excède pas ce soit 80 mille
euros que la vente de marchandises
objets fournitures et denrées à emporter
ou à consommer sur place soit en 2000
euros pour les prestations de services
cette demande qui émane des trois
chambres consulaires de la réunion
encouragerait les initiatives
individuelles à la création d'entreprise
merci monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission saisie au fond votre avis
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le régime
micro dont vous parlez madame la
sénatrice et déjà une niche fiscale
correspondant à un régime d'imposition
très avantageux qui n'a pas vocation ce
nous semble-t-il s'ajouter aux
dispositifs d et des femmes toutefois
nous sollicitons l'avis du gouvernement
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs madame la sénatrice le
gouvernement émet un avis défavorable à
votre amendement mais avec un accord sur
le fond de la nécessité d' expertiser
cette question là et avec un engagement
qu avant le passage devant l'assemblée
nationale on puisse vous apporter et
apporter des réponses sur ce problème
spécifique
notre crainte simplement c'est que
l'amendement tel qu'il est rédigé
pourrait aboutir à une situation moins
favorable aux entreprises que vous
évoquez qui paye vous savez un impôt
forfaitaire qu'elles le sont en réalité
donc il faut que nous puissions
expertiser les choses et si vous
acceptez sous ce principe là de retirer
votre amendement le gouvernement
s'engage à ce que des réponses soient
apportées très clairement sur les micro
entreprises avant le débat à l'assemblée
nationale madame aurore est ce que vous
le même pays où vous le retirez c'est à
l'invitation du gouvernement et des
précisions qui vous sans donner c'est à
vous de vous prononcer c'est adil est
parce que si je retire ça veut dire je
ne vais pas au fond d'après ce que je
reprends ce que je représente et ne pas
le retirer aussi ça veut dire je ne vous
crois pas totalement
donc je crois que je vais quand même le
maintenir le maintenir et puis bon on
verra la suite après monsieur le
ministre merci bien
alors il est maintenu il à l'avis
défavorable du gouvernement
pardon pour explication bottes vous avez
la parole mal un terrain monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues non bien d'entendre les
explications de monsieur le ministre
mais donc cet amendement porte comme
l'amendement précédent que nous avons
examiné hier soir sur le périmètre de la
mesure prévue à l'article 1er donc sur
le fond tout laisse même à penser que ce
sont les entreprises les plus pourvus en
fonds propres c'est à dire bien souvent
les entreprises détenues par les
familles exerçant de longue date le
pouvoir économique outre-mer qui vont
constituer les bénéficiaires potentiels
du dispositif exclut en effet les
entreprises soumis au régime micro et au
forfait de l'application du dispositif
de l'acdi pleut de l'article 1er
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
il part dont la lecture des données de
l'administration fiscale est très claire
près de trente mille entreprises
ressortant de l'imposition des bénéfices
industriels et commerciaux au titre de
l'impôt sur le revenu près de 8000
entreprises imposée au titre des
bénéfices non commerciaux et 85 % des
exploitants agricoles s'avère
aujourd'hui placé hors du champ
d'application de l'article 1er et quand
on fait notamment du développement de
l'agriculture l'une des clés du
développement durable de l'outre-mer
c'est là une situation pour le moins
complexe
de fait en exclu selon le cas comme
vient de le dire ma collègue des
entreprises réalisant un chiffre
d'affaires inférieur à 32000 euros pour
un prestataire de service ou 80000 euros
pour une entreprise d'achat revente
à titre d'illustration un regard sur le
répertoire des métiers à la réunion nous
indique que cette disposition exclu
d'office environ le quart des
entreprises artisanales
soit près de 3000 unités en 2007 il faut
savoir qu'une ce sont pas moins de 38 %
des nouveaux inscrits au registre du
commerce qui ont choisi le régime fiscal
micro par souci de simplification pour
se lancer un souci de simplification qui
accompagne bien souvent un souci
d'échapper au chômage puisqu'à la
réunion à la guadeloupe comme ailleurs
en outre-mer et en france la création
d'entreprise est souvent défini par les
acteurs comme une alternative à
l'inactivité ont créé son entreprise
pour ne pas rester sans emploi donc à
l'image des mesures en vigueur dans la
zone franche urbaine notamment celles de
la zone est qui autorise les
exploitations relevant du régime fiscal
micro à bénéficier des exonérations
fiscales
l'amendement 237 de notre collègue
gélita hoarau propose d'ouvrir le champ
de la zone franche globale aux
entreprises relevant de ce régime micro
en modifiant par l'adoption de cet
amendement donc l'article premier de ce
projet de loi ce que nous vous
recommandons d'adopter mes chers
collègues bien je vous remercie l'eau à
d'autres demandes de parole je mets aux
voileux 237 ceux qui sont favorables son
adoption veut bien levé la main avis
contraire il n'est pas adapté pour le
groupe socialiste qui présente
l'amendement 163 monsieur frais quand
vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président il s'agit pour
cet amendement 163 de permettre aux
entreprises guadeloupéennes de traverser
la crise et de distribuer davantage de
pouvoir d'achat leurs salariés nous y
étions tous d'accord sur 7 sur ce
principe hier soir il est donc proposé
ici de rendre plus attractifs les
avantages des zones franches d'activités
en relevant les plafonds prévus pour la
bande pour l'abattement sur les
bénéfices l'impôt sur les sociétés est
donc le texte de l'amendement dit le
porter la première somme de cent
cinquante mille euros à 250000 euros et
un peu plus loin dans le texte portait
la somme de 300 mille euros à 400000
euros vient à vis de la commission
ce free danse chemise mes chers
collègues l'avis de la commission est
défavorable
les plafonds déjà fixés sont très
avantageux le relèvement risquerait de
coûter cher aux finances publiques et de
favoriser davantage les entreprises les
plus importants ce qui n'est pas
l'objectif des et des femmes elle vit du
gouvernement défavorable bien pas de
demande explications de vote je mets aux
voix cet amendement qui a un avis
défavorable de la commission comme des
gouvernements ceux qui sont favorables
sens de l'option lève la main avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté maintenant
le 164 c'est le même défendeurs mesuré
quand vous avez la parole
264 est sur le même principe
c'est pour l'atténuation de la
dégressivité dans le temps des avantages
de la zdf a en effet ce dispositif n'est
prévu que pour 10 ans à l'issue des cinq
premières années de mise en oeuvre il
devient dégressif sur les cinq dernières
années pour s'éteindre à l'issue de la
10e par cet amendement nous proposons de
rendre moins brutale la sortie en
sifflet du dispositif pour l'impôt sur
les sociétés et pour la taxe foncière
sur les propriétés bâties pour la taxe
professionnelle il s'agit d'entériner sa
suppression dès 2009 et dans le texte de
l'amendement
vous voyez la sortie en sifflet telle
qu'elle vous est proposée au cours des
6e 7e 8e 9e année voilà la raison pour
laquelle nous présentons cette amende
je vous remercie avis de la commission
c'est une chaufferie dans celui de mes
chers collègues l'avis de la commission
est défavorable aussi les taux déjà
fixés par le projet de loi de 50% pour
le gym général et 80 pour les secteurs
prioritaires sont déjà favorables par
ailleurs ça serait très coûteux pour les
finances publiques
un gouvernement est favorable
défavorable bien et le sénat ceux qui
sont pour veulent bien levé la main avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté maintenant
nous avons 10 amendements qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion commune
je vais tout d'abord appelé le 160
rectifié monsieur larcher vous avez la
parole mais c'est le président chers
collègues site abandon porte sur
l'abattement sur le bénéfice imposable
dans la zones franches d'activités l'un
double un double double visée d'abord il
permet d'étendre le bénéfice du régime
modifier davantage en matière
d'imposition des bénéfices dans les
zones franches
tivité des dom à l'ensemble des
exploitations éligible au régime situé
dans certaines zones rurales dénommé
autre que la guyane fois moins
favorisées notamment par et pour des
raisons géographiques et climatiques
il s'agit par exemple des hauts de la
réunion ii du nord basse terre
guadeloupe ou du nord atlantique car
ayem de la martinique s'est dit dans
cette identification des zones devraient
être fixées par décret en conseil d'état
suit cet amendement vise à simplifier et
harmoniser entre les différents
départements d'outre-mer la délimitation
des secteurs prioritaires où
s'appliquera le vg bonifie davantage en
matière d'imposition des bénéfices
compte tenu de la place également
déterminante occupé dans le
développement de ce département par les
secteurs du tourisme de l'agro nutrition
et des énergies renouvelables
ces deux derniers secteurs des temps
d'ailleurs pas dépourvue des liens de
lier l'abonnement proposé à moins de les
identifier distinctement comme
d'ailleurs les secteurs de recherche et
développement et technologies de
l'information et de la communication
afin d'éviter toute ambiguïté
préjudiciable à l'intelligibilité à
l'intelligibilité de la loi de même
est-il précisé le secteur du tourisme
doit être largement attendue et inclure
en particulier les activités de loisirs
s'y rapportant activités de loisirs de
bord de mer de rivière de sites naturels
etc
je remercie mais ces jeux je vais
appeler maintenant le 281
et fier madame va y est vous le présente
s il vous plait il s'agit du même
amendement monsieur le président
j'aimerais simplement précisé car la
réunion ces zones rurales sont les hauts
de la réunion défini dernièrement comme
parc national et qu'il s'agit d'une zone
de montagne confrontés à un taux de
chômage de près de 40 % et même 50% dans
mon village et à une défaillance de
formation de sa population qui a la
particularité d'être très jeune je
remercie je vous remercie monsieur
virapoullé ce que vous voulez bien
présenter votre amendement 271 il pas
vous laisser troubler temps avec plaisir
l'amendement a pour objet d'étendre le
bénéfice du régime bonifier davantage en
matière d'imposition des bénéfices des
zones franches d'activités des dom à
l'ensemble des exploitations éligible en
zones franches d'activités situés dans
certaines zones rurales qui sont
particulièrement défavorisées comme ça a
été le cas pour la guyane et notamment
raison en fonction des raisons
géographiques et thématiques
je veux parler des hauts de la réunion
du nord de basse-terre en guadeloupe du
nord atlantique de la martinique
les identifications desdites zones étant
fixée pour certains déjà par décret en
conseil d'état comme pour les hauts de
la réunion
et pour sceller les régions qui ne font
pas l'objet d'un décret mais le décret
sera pris par ailleurs c'est un
amendement que j'ai fait suite à une
mission vous m'avez confiées à un seul
ministre avec le député le breton et qui
avait pour but de ne pas d'avoir une
politique équilibrée aux halles dans nos
régions parce qu'aujourd'hui suspens
l'île de la réunion le développement se
fait surtout sur le littoral alors que
le des deux tiers des surfaces
c'est vrai compris des montagnes se
situe dans les eaux si on pouvait
développer en même temps que le zones
littorales les eaux nous aurions un
aménagement équilibré de notre
territoire une répartition équilibrée de
la population et c'est aussi une forme
d'équité sociale bien je vais maintenant
appeler l'onu
16 qui vont se présenter par madame
michaud chevry et la parole à la
présidente qui ne card pour un peu
traumatisé le seul ministre parce que je
viens d'entendre tout à l'heure des
collègues de la guyane de la martinique
et de la réunion par les dunes aux
masters je leur dit m merci mais moi je
voulais parler du sud basse terre
un seul mini ce mois-là le développement
qui est fait depuis 33 ans guadeloupe
toute la zone bleue c'est le port
l'aéroport
les 300 millions que l'état mais pour
abymes pointe-à-pitre
c'est la recherche c'est les éoliennes
fait où est implanté maintenant toute
l'administration c'est le départ de ses
mates et saint-barthélemy au détriment
de la basse terre sans qu'il y ait une
modification de la carte judiciaire pour
maintenir sur place tout ce qui est en
rouge c'est ce qui est abandonnée
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire la queue de
solaire il ya trop de vent pour les
éoliennes
depuis les événements de la soufrière
1976 cette zone est abandonné non je
demande d'ajouter à marie galante les
selles désirade et madame payet désir il
n'y a pas de zone rurale ni à tintin
bras ni arnaud la zone rurale elle est
là elle est un jeune de montagne c'est
la raison pour laquelle je sais que vous
allez faire des propositions que les
avis seront défavorables mais je voulais
vous traumatiser vous dire qu'est ce que
je fais de cette zone où j'ai des jeunes
le seul ministre et le soir je vais
m'asseoir avec même si parfois ils sont
chouchoutés et une voulons dit monsieur
le ministre en franchise
on a rien à faire et parfois pour
s'amuser en bout il des poubelles
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait là et à ce
fort je me sens pas il y un patrimoine à
développer rien et brief heureusement
que cette zone là à ma foi mais je la
ferai entendre croyez moi encore très
longtemps bien monsieur le 377 monsieur
martin vous avez la parole en tant que
rapporteur parcelles et le président et
ses ministres mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise également à
harmoniser les secteurs prioritaires
définis par défini pour la guadeloupe la
martinique et la réunion
en effet le dispositif des zones
franches d'activités créées par le
présent projet de loi peut voir dans
deux taux un taux de 50 % pour
l'ensemble des entreprises éligibles et
un taux bonifié de 80% pour les
territoires puis à 8 heures et les
secteurs prioritaires parmi ces secteurs
prioritaires il ya donc la recherche
développement et les technologies de
l'information ce sont des secteurs a
priori de droit ainsi que trois secteurs
définis par les acteurs locaux
guadeloupéens martiniquais et veuille ou
non les sétois secteurs prioritaires en
réalité choisi par la guadeloupe la
martinique et la leyou sont très proches
et présente un potentiel similaire dans
les trois départements
la distinction opérée n'a presque pas
d'intérêt là cet amendement propose donc
afin de simplifier les choses et de
rendre plus efficace le dispositif est
bien d'harmoniser ce secteur à
l'ensemble des trois départements ce qui
fait qu'en plus des deux secteurs de
droit déjà prévu recherche développement
et technologie de l'information et bien
qu'on ajoute tout simplement dans les
quatre autres départements torisme ago
nutrition environnement et énergies
renouvelables je vous remercie je vais
demander au ministre nous présenter le
388 qui me paraît très proche du vôtre
il est retiré il est retiré bien alors
le 270 de monsieur virapoullé le 270
vous êtes dissiper aujourd'hui un nom il
vélo et défende une mission bien et
maintenant madame aarau vous en avez 3 à
défendre un après l'autre de la parole
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
bon c'est un amendement qui certainement
je suis sûr que ça va être rejetée mais
quand même je le dis parce que c'est
quand même lié à l'amendement de 136 qui
a été rejetée mais je le je vais quand
même essayer de le défendre
aussi pour préserver un secteur
pourvoyeur d'emplois et acteurs de
l'aménagement du territoire les chambres
consulaires de la réunion ont manifesté
le souhait que le petit commerce soit
intégrée à la future zones franches
globales d'activité en tant que secteur
prioritaire le 239 ça concerne les
services à la personne et on se dit
qu'elle mérite que ses services mais
rique d'être favorisés donc intégré
comme comme secteur prioritaire de la
zone franche globale d'activité en
raison du déficit de personnel de
structures dans ce domaine quand on sait
que c'est un secteur d'avenir et qui
emploie beaucoup de personnes le 240 bon
ça rejoint d'autres amendements essais
concernant les zones de montagne qui
connaissent non seulement un déficit
démographique mais également un retard
en matière de développement économique
à titre d'illustration la densité en
emploi constaté dans les eaux est
nettement plus faible 30 de poissons
d'emplois en moins que celle des bas
donc pour harmoniser le développement
économique et contribuer à la menace
je mens du territoire fixation des
populations et diminution des
déplacements
nous demandons que les activités
économiques situés en zone rurale soit
éligible à la future zones franches
globales d'activité en tant que secteur
prioritaire
je vous remercie oui c'est parfait tout
dit je vais demander aux rapporteurs de
la commission saisie au fond monsieur
matte nation de nous commenter son avis
sur les neuf amendements récentes
discussions puisque le 388 a été retiré
oui monsieur le président sioniste du
show collègues sur le 160 rectifier la
commission est favorable à
l'harmonisation des secteurs éligibles
aux dispositifs préférentiels et et des
femmes toutefois il conviendra que le
gouvernement nous éclaire sur la
situation économique et sociale des
communes visées afin d'évaluer si
l'application large du régime
préférentiel et est opportune ou non sur
le 281 rectifier cet amendement a le
même objectif que l'amendement précédent
et donc la commission sollicite l'avis
du gouvernement sur le 271 également un
rendement proche du 160 rectifier que
l'on a vu tout à l'heure donc l'avis du
gouvernement est sollicité l'amendement
numéro 16 de madame michaux-chevry
le projet de loi prévoit dans le cas des
dfa la possibilité d'appliquer un
abattement préférentiel de 80 % au lieu
de l'abattement base 50% l'intégralité
de la guyane des idées simples marie
galante et la désirade sont éligibles à
ce trou préférentiels l'amendement
prévoit d'inclure dans cette liste la
côte sous le vent
d'une part cette appellation est
imprécise et ne permet pas d'identifier
la zone géographique clair
d'autre part le dispositif préférentiels
a vocation à s'appliquer uniquement aux
territoires les plus défavorisés pour en
conserver le caractère incitatif donc
il vous est demandé le retrait chers
collègues amendement 377 avis favorable
sur le principe mais il semble déjà
avoir obtenu satisfaction avec le 160 le
388 et retiré un amendement 270 à vis du
gouvernement mais s'il est d'accord il
pourrait être retiré au profit de
l'amendement 160 rectifié amendement 238
le dispositif préférentiel d'abattement
des dfa vocation à s'appliquer au
secteur porteur d'un développement
économique endogène des territoires et
non à soutenir le petit commerce avis
défavorable le 239 le disent c'est la
même c'est le même explication donc avis
défavorable et le 240 le gouvernement a
semble-t-il étudier l'opportunité
d'étendre à certaines régions
défavorisées le dispositif préférentiel
d'abattement des dfa il conviendra donc
que le gouvernement est claire la
commission sur la situation économique
et sociale des zones pouvant nécessiter
une extension de ce dispositif
ainsi vous un menteur monsieur le
ministre votre avis alors sur le premier
amendement le 160 rectifiée présentée
par monsieur le sénateur larcher le
gouvernement donne un avis favorable à
cet amendement et demande effectivement
à ce qu'ils puissent être votées
puisqu'il correspond il correspondait à
l'amendement du gouvernement 388 que
j'ai retiré au profit de l'amendement
sénatorial et qu' il est
évidemment il va dans le sens de du
choix du secteur de l'agro nutrition qui
est pour nous un secteur prioritaire de
ce fait il pourrait permettre à madame
payet de retirer l'amendement 280
puisqu'il se trouve satisfait par cette
demande il pourrait permettre à monsieur
virapoullé de retirer l'article 271 qui
lui aussi est fin et satisfait par cette
demande
la demande le numéro 16 alors je vais
être un ministre polytraumatisé mais moi
je suis très sensible madame a les
arguments que vous évoquez à la carte
que vous nous présentez à la définition
de la côte sous le vent qui me semblait
une définition géographique qu'à une
cohérence
je crains simplement que si on ouvre la
porte sur ce sujet a rajouté des zones à
côté des zones sont des définitions plus
précises que celles qui existent déjà
les îles du sud comme étant évidemment
la double insularité les hauts de la
réunion qui sont déjà reconnus dans un
zonage on risque de courir le risque
complètement de définition des
périmètres d'eau que moi est ce que je
serais tenter de vous proposer séclier
une action un schéma spécifique qui soit
élaborée mais c'est un engagement
prendrait le gouvernement qui pourrait
aboutir à un contrat de développement
spécifique à ce secteur géographique qui
mobiliserait des crédits du fonds
exceptionnel d'investissement des
crédits du fonds fisac pour l'outre-mer
puisqu'il est créé dans ce projet de loi
que nous puissions aboutir avant
l'automne à l'élaboration de ce schéma
spécifique de développement et que nous
puissions ainsi apporter les réponses
très pratique au développement à la
jeunesse que vous avez évoqué du secteur
de basse terre je sais que vous y êtes
particulièrement attaché je crois que
des équipements structurants comme le
fort delgrès ce pourait
avoir une vocation très forte en matière
culturelle que la guadeloupe est à une
partie économique autour de
pointe-à-pitre qu'elle peut avoir aussi
une capitale culturelle autour de basse
terre c'est peut-être par cette
proposition de schéma cohérent de
développement de cette partie de la
guadeloupe que nous pourrions apporter
une réponse concrète à votre demande si
vous acceptiez face à cet engagement
précis du gouvernement de retirer votre
amendement
j'y serai sensible l'amendement de
monsieur marc st lui aussi tombe du fait
de l'acceptation du 160 rectifier c'est
un avis favorable du gouvernement mais
il est satisfait par le 160 rectifié
ainsi que 270 de jean paul virapoullé le
238 de madame hoarau sur le petit
commerce
vous l'avez défendu avec conviction je
vous ferai la même réponse est que le
petit commerce va bénéficier de mesures
importantes d'un fonds fisac spécial de
prêts et que nous sommes en train
d'étudier ou d'accès aux de soutien à
l'accès au crédit pour les commerçants
et plus de baisses de charges qui sont
importantes puisque nous vous proposons
dans ce texte d'introduire 75 millions
d'euros de baisses de charges pour les
entreprises de moins de onze salariés et
que ce sont notamment des entreprises du
commerce donc nous donnons un avis
défavorable non pas au petit commerce
mais à l'amendement tel qu'il est
présenté 238 nous donnons aussi un avis
défavorable 239 tout simplement ce que
les services aux particuliers sont déjà
intégrés dans le périmètre des zones
franches d'activités qui a donc pas lieu
de les réintégrer et enfin un avis
défavorable aux 240 puisque votre
amendement et je suppose que vous aviez
à l'esprit en parlant des zones de
montagne les hauts de la réunion est
satisfait par l'amendement qui était
accepté
on le sent 60 rectifié donc il n'a plus
vraiment lieu d'être
voilà les avis du gouvernement si
monsieur le président les porteurs des
amendements qu'ils sont satisfaits par
l'avis favorable sur le 160 rectifié
l'accepter nous pourrions je crois
simplifier le vote manami chevrier ce
que vous retirer votre amendement parce
qu'il va tomber donc ses ministres en
1982 le gouvernement a créé un monsieur
de la côte sous-le-vent et mais je veux
quand même qu'on respecte l'histoire
je n'ai pas déposé un amendement pour
déposer nabeul la guadeloupe est coupée
selon son sein un certain nombre de
zones
les histoires des îles du sud ça a été
aussi créé de toutes pièces puisque
désir n'est pas dans le sud est et le
mail et dans le support des cycles on a
créé les îles du sud
en comparaison aux îles du nord quand je
me dis qu'il ya pas de zone à jeudi non
parce que l'europe dans les contrats de
plan des départements et territoires
d'outre-mer
il y à des zones et cette zone a et d
éviter depuis la soufrière bon le
ministre dit mais nous allons je
m'engage je le crois mais vous comprenez
que depuis 1982 nous attendons et
développement de cette zone
et qu'est ce que nous constatons que
toutes nos propositions ne font l'objet
d'aucune réponse positive alors d'accord
je veux pas vous traumatiser je retire
mais je crois que je vais vous
traumatiser d'autant plus quand vous
bombardant de convier de l'eau si bien
alors monsieur ministre avant de mettre
aux voix l'amendement 160 rectifié sur
les avances si vous levez le gage bien
je vous en remercie monsieur marin vous
retirer le vôtre mars un ballon vous
êtes toujours libre d'intervenir en tant
que rapporteur nous avez la parole voilà
oui je profite pour dire que mon
amendement 377 est satisfait par cet
amendement donc il va tomber il n'y a
pas de problème par contre j'en viens à
l'amendement 160 rectifier chi chi chi
et qui présente un réel intérêt
nous interrompons l'examen du projet de
loi pour le développement économique de
l'outre-mer pour tout de suite prendre
la direction de l'école militaire de
paris où nicolas sarkozy doit prononcer
un discours très attendu sur la
réintégration de la france dans l'otan
je vous rappelle que la france avait
quitté l'alliance atlantique en 1966 sur
décision du général de gaulle
aujourd'hui c'est un retour controversé
dans le commandement intégré
certains parlementaires ump redoutant
est la perte d'indépendance de la france
pour la socialiste martine aubry
rien ne justifie le retour de la france
dans l'otan si ce n'est un atlantisme
qui devient une idéologie mais pour le
ministre des affaires étrangères bernard
kouchner cette participation permettra
d'accroître l'influencé de la france et
de renforcer le point de vue européen au
sein de l'alliance
donc on écoute tout de suite le
président de la république qui devrait
consacrer le retour de la france dans
l'otan
donc quand leur public c'est un grand
honneur que vous faites à notre
fondation
en venant clôturer cette journée d'étude
par un discours important et ce en
présence du premier ministre des membres
du gouvernement et des hautes
personnalités étrangères qui ont pris
part à nos débats de la journée il
m'incombe d'essayer de vous résumer en
cinq minutes 7 maximum cette journée qui
a été très riche en échanges et qui
comme je l'aï dit nous a permis de faire
entendre dans le débat français dans
débat national
le point de vue de nos partenaires
européens et alliés je pense que les
discussions ont fait apparaître trois
trois faits saillants le premier
concerne l'europe est apparu de manière
assez unanimes une un sou et convergents
de faire progresser encore l'europe de
la défense est bien entendu le traité de
lisbonne
d comme on espère qu'il entrera en
vigueur permettra des avancées
institutionnelles majeures seul aidant
il a été souligné que les progrès
sociaux neil ont peu d'impact
si la réalité militaire n'est pas à la
hauteur des ambitions et dont chacun a
souligné l'importance que les nations
européennes consentent un effort de
défense à la hauteur de l'analyse des
menaces d'aujourd'hui et de demain
le deuxième point saillant concerne
l'alliance atlantique
ici encore personne n'a remis en cause
la nécessité et l'utilité de cette
alliance
alors qu'il ya dix ans on se posait
parfois cette question mais le besoin
s'est fait sentir de clarifier sur le
plan politique et militaire ces grands
objectifs en profitant notamment de la
discussion sur un nouveau concept
stratégique nouveau concept stratégique
de l'otan qui devra évidemment tenir
compte de l'émergence de nouvelles
menaces y compris très loin
géographiquement lointaine le cas
échéant et aussi des avancées
institutionnelles de l'union européenne
l'afghanistan est évidemment été
mentionné comme un test très important à
court terme
le troisième point était un peu moins
consensuel et signale une certaine
singularité du débat stratégique
français qui a été évoqué par
certains intervenants il s'agit du lien
de la relation entre la défense ur des
progrès la défense européenne et
l'alliance atlantique
tout le monde a compris que pour nos
partenaires européens
les progrès la défense européenne et
l'engagement dans l'otan non seulement
sont pas incompatibles mais sont
absolument inséparables en france la
situation n'est pas tout à fait aussi
clair puisque depuis 40 ans l'otan est
souvent perçu moins comme un espace de
solidarité entre européens que comme une
institution largement dominé par les
états unis
l'opinion française même éclairé ne sait
pas grand chose de la réalité de
l'engagement de la france dans l'otan
par exemple tous les intervenants quelle
que soit leur sensibilité ont reconnu
que sur le plan technique et juridique
le retour le plein retour de la france
dans la structure de commandement
l'obligé en rien à modifier les grands
principes de notre défense encore moins
à affecter notre indépendance de
décision
notre autonomie nucléaire toutefois il y
a deux sensibilités qui se sont exprimés
pour les ans conscient de la tante
exprimé par tous nos partenaires
européens en faveur d'un nouveau geste
de la france vers l'otan
certains pensent que ce mouvement faire
l'otan facilitera et même a déjà
commencé à faciliter les progrès de la
défense européenne sort de paris dit
saadi l'un des intervenants à paris
rationnel et raisonnable d'autres sont
plus sceptiques s'interroge sur le
l' avantage que nous tirons de ce
mouvement par rapport à la préservation
du consensus national ou à une certaine
matches à l'extérieur
d'autres enfin se demande si les
européens auront la volonté de faire de
l'ambition européenne une réalité c'est
dire que le débat n'est en rien un débat
technique mais essentiellement un débat
de nature politique
c'est à ce niveau qui doit être tranché
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le président un public
il est temps que je m'efface et que je
cède ma place à la tribu
monsieur le premier ministre
cher françois messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
monsieur secrétaire général de l'otan
monsieur le secrétaire général aux
représentants de l'union européenne
servier enfin monsieur le président
d'information pour la recherche
stratégique
et si vous le permettez mesdames et
messieurs je veux d'abord merci bruno
racine d'avoir pris l'initiative de ce
colloque parce qu'il est étonnant qu'on
soit partisan de l'otan qu'on soit
adversaires ont réservé il ya une chose
qu'on devrait avoir en commun c'est le
souci d'éclairer l'opinion et d'en
débattre
qu'est ce que sont ces responsables
politiques qui affirmerait des
convictions par ailleurs extrêmement
légitime quelle qu'elle soit
ce qu'il est illégitime c'est de ne pas
aller jusqu'au bout de sa logique et de
ne pas informer les français sur la
réalité de le temps et la réalité de la
participation de la france au sein de
l'otan
ça c'est un point qui doit éclairer tout
le monde ce que j'ai découvert avec le
point ministère le gouvernement
c'est qu'alors que nous sommes dans le
temps car nous y sommes mais il ya bien
peu de personnes qui le savent
n'est-il donc des activités si secrète
call of s'abstenir d'expliquer aux
français ce qu'on y fait souvent parler
du mot rupture
s'il ya bien une rupture c'est celle de
ce gouvernement dans la transparence des
décisions qu'ils assument
j'y reviendrai c'est un débat qui doit
être mené et donc monsieur le président
vous avez une raison puis vous n'aurez
lycée dans l'amphithéâtre foch
c'est tout un symbole il fut le premier
commandant en chef des forces alliées
européennes et américaines pendant la
première guerre mondiale
le concept d'allier et d'amis ne date
pas du début de mon quinquennat alors
fois c'est le sentiment d'avoir c'est
que c'est tout nouveau donc mais
faciliter la tâche dans l'amphithéâtre
foch brno race il a bien présenté les
conclusions de votre débat avec la
capacité de synthèse inégalable et la
sienne et avec la courtoisie faut que je
traduise différences de sensibilité
violence de confrontation des opinions
eh bien tant que chef des armées et donc
garant de la défense des intérêts vitaux
et de la sécurité de la france
moi je porte la responsabilité des choix
stratégiques de la nation et je voudrais
affirmer une première idée c'est que
notre réflexion stratégique ne peut pas
rester figés dans un monde où les
conditions de notre sécurité ont
radicalement changé